[Music]
well the heavens on earth was something
of an extension of my previous books I
had not covered the afterlife in any
kind of detail from my previous books on
the paranormal the supernatural religion
God morality and so this is sort of a
natural extension of well if you're
skeptical of all these other things what
about the afterlife and you know my
standard one-liner is I'm for it but the
fact that I'm four doesn't make it true
in fact if anything the more
passionately we want something to be
true the more skeptical we should be of
our own beliefs because we know how
powerful these cognitive biases are to
lead us to want to find evidence for
what we already want to be true so I
really kind of went in search of just
all the standard religious theories of
the afterlife in heaven I go through the
MOT great they big three monotheism
Judaism Christianity and Islam and you
know right right there all of them have
a history in the sense of all the
different versions that there are of the
afterlife in heaven and they're quite
different histories than say if you read
a history of cosmology which sort of
shows a progression from the ancients
through the scientific revolution you
know through the early modern period all
the way up to today of us getting closer
and closer to a understanding of the
real nature of the cosmos but there's
nothing like that in religious histories
of the afterlife they're all scattershot
this theory this theory there's no
there's no sense of progress that alone
tells us that these are culturally
determined geographically located like
reincarnation the belief that we come
back in this world our soul somehow
migrated into other bodies why do they
seem to hover all those souls in the
subcontinent of India you know there's
very few other places around the world
where the soul seemed to go that's an
indication that these things are not
real out there in the real world sense
but real inside people's heads as
determined by their cultures but the
core of heavens on earth really is the
scientific search for the afterlife and
since this is what I do science writing
and research and scientific areas
believe it or not this is no longer a
fringe idea this idea that we could live
forever there are there are scientists
today who say that the first person to
live a thousand years is alive today
okay
I'm skeptical okay but still these
aren't fringe nuts
these are billionaires like Peter Thiel
Jeff Bezos of Amazon the Google guys
Larry and Sergey have invested you know
hundreds of millions of dollars in this
company calico you know Ray Kurzweil is
their chief engineer and who believes in
the singularity so this whole idea of
radical life extension cryonics
transhumanism
you know the singularity we're gonna
upload our minds into a computer
these are form the core center of my
book and why I'm skeptical why really
all of us should be skeptical because
first although it's not impossible that
that these researchers and scientists
are wrong it's just very unlikely
because the problems of say duplicating
your soul whatever that would be in
science that would be your pattern of
information your genome and then the
equivalent of that your connectome that
is the the tracings of all your memories
everything that's you this is their
theory you you copy it and you upload it
into a computer let's say you have it
backed up every night when you die you
just put it into a clone or inside a
computer or something like that that's
the idea and I think the the
underestimation of the complexity of the
problem is is orders of magnitude off
and we are not even close to doing
anything like this
I mean Ray Kurzweil projects 2040 is the
singularity and after that you know we
might be able to live forever how is
that gonna happen and who's the we okay
so then I have a chapter on who are we
who are you
what what does it mean to be you and and
so their idea is that if we just copied
your memories it would be you stop right
there
which memories at what age 20 30 50 60
the memories are not stored in there
like video tape like you just play it
back on the theater your mind and there
it is what really happened when you were
15 or whatever no they're they're
constantly edited and changed that those
neural networks are reworked
constantly so there is no real you in
any snapshot sense of that moment right
there is the time when you're you know
such thing and then finally there's the
through your eyes perspective what's
called a point of view self so the
memory self mem self is what I just
described it is the point of view self
which is you know me looking out of my
eyes at you right now and you you
looking out at me and now when I go to
sleep tonight there's a disruption in my
conscious point of view but it comes
back in the morning and if I go under
general anesthesia it's gone for a
couple hours comes back a little groggy
at first but it comes clear if I died
and then copied my brain and put it in a
computer turn the computer on am I
suddenly inside the computer looking at
the little you know camera hole I don't
think so
and here's why because if we did this
while you were alive let's say the
current technology would be that after
you die we take your brain out and slice
it and scan every single synaptic
connection and then take that big data
mass and put it into a computer now in
the future we may be maybe in five
hundred years or something we could scan
your brain while you're living and and
scan through sophisticated MRI type
technology every single neural
connection let's say we could do that
now and get your connectome and put it
into computer while you're standing
right there a lot so we turn it on who's
that in there in the computer when
you're standing right there okay you see
the problem because you're not gonna be
standing there going yeah there I am in
the computer no you're gonna be standing
there going nah me no more than a twin
we look at their other twin and go yeah
they're right there I go no so I don't
think even that even if they could
accomplish the technology of it it's
still not you being put into the future
in terms of an afterlife and by the way
I think religions have the same problem
you know when Christians talk about
you're gonna wake up with Jesus up in
heaven okay but but I'm actually still
down on the ground there no no no that's
your body your soul wait what is the
soul what it's all your memories and
your you know it's you uh which part of
me is is going to heaven what age and so
on same problem it's just a copy going
to heaven I'm still in the ground I'm
still dead it's just some copy of me I'm
not waking up in heaven through my point
of view okay so that's the core of the
book
and then in the subtitle of the book the
scientific search for the afterlife
immortality and utopia so I do i do
approach the problem of creating heavens
on earth like if okay if we can't live
forever maybe we can create a perfect
world here no I haven't no you can't
can't do it this is why they've always
failed utopias always fail because there
is no such place that's the very
definition of utopia nowhere there's no
such places perfect because we're so
variable then people differ in their
needs and wants and desires that this is
if anything been a dystopia the search
for utopia has led to dystopia because
we all bury so even that doesn't work so
I conclude that at the end sort of a
discussion of what does it all mean
where do we find meaning and purpose in
life if this is all there is and if you
think about it even if there is an
afterlife even if there is a heaven this
is the most important thing now not to
here after but the here and now and the
relationships you have and how you
engage with the world and other people
that's what counts now so make the most
of it
[Music]